on va paraître cette manifestation l'a
dit à peu près dans 81 villes françaises
pourquoi la loi sécurité globale
manifestement pose problème mon ami
faouzi et jacques mignaux voulons 10g et
une loi complètement aberrante
ne serait-ce que l'article 24 qu'on n'en
a pas besoin puisque ça existe déjà dans
la loi française il suffirait
d'appliquer la loi française
je voudrais vous rappeler que l'article
8 de la convention européenne
l'article 9 du code civil l'article
221-1 du code pénal réprimant tu déjà
toute atteinte à la vie privée et à
l'image de quelqu'un pourquoi faire une
fois de plus c'est uniquement pour faire
plaisir à certains policiers qui font
des bavures
c'est uniquement parce que la police
aujourd'hui est le dernier rempart le
dernier rempart du fait que macro existe
encore qu'il protège au maximum ces gens
là vous rendez compte que dans l'oise
sécurité globale ils vont aussi mettre
un article qui va permettre à la police
municipale de faire des actions
judiciaires
je rappelle quand même que la police est
sous les ordres de la de la juridiction
nationale la police municipale
c'est le maire qui va commander avec
toutes les dérives qu'on peut connaître
chez certes amère cette la globalité de
cette loi est uniquement une loi
sécuritaire qui nous va nous rapprocher
de la corée du nord alors l'exécutif en
tout cas c'est justifié un et et a bien
dit qu'il ne s'agissait pas d' empêcher
de filmer les policiers dans l'exercice
de leurs missions en tout cas mais
seulement de diffuser les images
alors si elle s'avérait
en tout cas un malveillantes et scott
est ce que non mais est ce que c'est un
argument zèle à revenir à la fin de ma
question monsieur parce qu est-ce que
c'est un argument que vous arrivez à
entendre non mais attendez j'ai le droit
de filmer mais j'ai pas le droit de
diffuser mais c'est quoi cette connerie
c'est quoi cette connerie
par contre peu en droit de filmer peut
on le droit de nous ficher jacques l'a
très bien dit aujourd'hui ils ont fait
un fichier où on peut même nous nous
ficher de façon sexuelle amira donc cela
la loi dans cela allait dans un seul
sens pourquoi les policiers ont pas le
droit de fumer si si ils font
correctement leur travail
il n'y a pas de problème là où il ya un
problème c'est quand il ya des
brutalités policières
là où il ya un problème c'est quand il
ya des bavures mais regarder des images
de policiers qui font bien leur boulot
ça pose aucun problème
ces gens-là hopper et les policiers qui
font des bavures ont peur donc comme ils
peuvent faire pression sur le
gouvernement
ils s'en servent comme dans les
policiers il ya un petit groupe il faut
le reconnaître
deux policiers fasciste de policiers qui
n'hésitent pas à faire des bavures et on
l'a vu avec le producteur de disques des
gens qui rentrent chez vous des gens qui
vous insultent des gens qui vous traîne
par terre
c'est sûr que ces gens là ne veulent pas
qu'on les films ces gens là ne veulent
pas qu'on montre leur tête et c'est pour
ça que macron protège ces gens là parce
qu'il en a besoin pour ne pas tomber
cette loi parce que l'exécutif est parti
du constat qu'il fallait protéger nos
forces de l'ordre manifestement il ya un
lien de confiance qui est rompu avec les
policiers en france une partie de la
population pourquoi aller avant q vous
venez de dire le bon mot
cette loi est faite pour protéger une
certaine partie de la police or je suis
désolé la loi aux priorités c'est
d'abord pour protéger les populations et
les plus en plus des lois qui sont
faites qui sont posés des décrets ou des
ordonnances
parce que la plupart du temps c'est fait
en douce je signale que normalement
l'article 24
il devrait même pu exister ils ont pris
des engagements comme d'habitude ils
disent et ils font le contraire la loi
aujourd'hui est fait pour protéger vous
l'avez bien
certains policiers elle est parfaite
pour protéger la population et ça c'est
une jour et vous vous rendez compte
nadège c'est un petit peu trompé malgré
la pluie malgré le coc vide malgré le
froid
malgré la répression malgré le fait
qu'on ne peut même plus se rendre sur
manifestation il y a encore des milliers
de gens dans la rue dans 80
manifestations en france et ça c'est
formidable et ça malheureusement une
fois de plus notre gouvernement qui
quelque part est sourd et aveugle ne
veut pas voir ne se rend pas compte que
le peuple est dans la rue
ça va finir par lui péter à la figure
fait des pas parce qu merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
rappel vous êtes écrivain ancien adjoint
municipal de manuel valls
merci à vous d'avoir un chirurgien va
très bien j'ai écrit un livre très bien
que vous n'avez pas cité qui s'appelle
mensonge d'état avec un s ça veut dire
ce que ça veut dire
très bien merci à vous monsieur pasqua